quand il est venu faire un état des
lieux à la demande des propriétaires
eugenio n'aurais jamais imaginé
découvrir un tel spectacle
là on se trouve dans la porcherie de
fermes et quand on arrivait et qu'on a
fait le tour général de la propriété
c'est là où vraiment on est écoeuré
écoeuré de voir des animaux tels qu'ils
sont là enfermé sans eau sans nourriture
et qui étaient enfermés jusqu'à la mort
des cadavres de bêtes momifié des restes
de squelettes les traces d'une histoire
macabre qui s'est déroulée entre ses
murs durant plusieurs années
en grattant un peu avec le pied on a
retrouvé l'oreillette du veau qui se
trouve ici
on retrouve donc sa date de naissance
apparemment ce que vaut ce rennais en
il a dû mourir en 2011 2012 est encore
là il n'a jamais bougé
le gardien contacte alors le refuge de
thiais renaît et une enquêtrice est
mandatée à son tour elle prend
connaissance de la maltraitance des
bêtes et de l'insalubrité des lieux
c'est un problème humain quoi au départ
c'est clair ce monsieur s'il avait eu
besoin des deals aurait pu contacter
tous les refuges de la nièvre
on lui aurait donné à l'est les moyens
de s'en sortir s'il avait des problèmes
pour gérer
il n'a pas assumé quoi il y a deux ans
déjà cet exploitant avait reçu une
amende pour avoir laissé périr plusieurs
animaux et ces bêtes lui avait été
retiré aujourd'hui les services
vétérinaires de l'état lui donne
jusqu'au 3 juin pour nettoyer les lieux